[Music]
Henry Cavill had to choose between a
super powerful metahuman who fights for
justice and one that fights for coin now
fans have opinions and conspiracies
about the choice arguably Henry cavill's
two most iconic roles Superman from the
DC Universe and geralt Rivia from The
Witcher have simultaneously found their
way back into the social Spotlight for
very different reasons in the weeks
leading up to the release of Black Adam
Dwayne The Rock Johnson's anti-hero
passion project it was revealed by The
Rock himself that Superman would make a
guest appearance as the role had been
absent from a slew of recent DC projects
and because Capital remained silent
about his status as a member of the dceu
the general population assumed that he
was done with DC now however it's been
confirmed by cavil himself on Instagram
that he will be returning to the DC
Universe for more superman-centric
content almost immediately after that
news dropped it was revealed that
Netflix had hired Liam Hemsworth to take
over the role of geralt Rivia for The
Witcher starting with the newly
confirmed fourth season because of the
timing these two pieces of information
feel connected as if Warner Brothers
would require all of kavel's time moving
forward and yet to choose between the
two roles that feels logical but there's
another potential theory behind cavill's
departure and it looks to carry some
weight fans took to Twitter to share
their view on the situation as the idea
of Henry Cavill leaving The Witcher just
to give DC his entire Focus didn't align
with his previous statements on the
subject for context in a 2021 Interview
With The Hollywood Reporter Cavill
promised his ongoing commitment to the
series provided that the content
remained faithful to the source material
specifically the outlet wrote the actor
remains committed to supporting
historic's Vision to keep The Witcher
going for at least seven seasons
absolutely cavil says as long as we can
keep telling great stories which honor
author Andre savkovsky's work with that
in mind one Twitter user tweeted I like
how everyone thinks Henry Cavill left
because the Superman rule paid more but
there's info out there confirming that
lot of people working on The Witcher
hated the source material and the games
Henry probably didn't want to continue
his contract and work with them that
information can be found in articles
where it's revealed that Beau de Mayo a
previous producer for The Witcher
claimed the writers for the Netflix
series actively despised both Andre
safkovsky's books and CD projekt Reds
games If This Were proven to be true
then it would explain why Capital
continued to do interviews where He
suggests he would love for subsequencies
and to stay loyal to the books this
could mean that Cavill would have left
The Witcher with or without the safety
net of more DC projects coming down the
pipeline
bless her greater
middling
it's all the same while it has yet to be
officially confirmed if the writers
chose to score in the source material
more and more fans are latching on to
the narrative one tweet said I'm upset
that Henry Cavill is leaving The Witcher
but I'm even more upset at the audacity
of the Netflix writers in thinking they
can do better than savkowsky's novels
especially after season two proved that
they in fact cannot while another tweet
declared this show is done season two
was pretty bad so makes sense that Henry
Cavill left he said he wanted Netflix to
be true to the source material no one
seems to Harbor animosity towards Liam
Hemsworth for joining the cast but most
fans have stated that they can't even
fathom another actor in the role polite
indifference to Hemsworth's resume boost
doesn't necessarily equate to viewers
for Netflix if social media is any
indicator of the future of the series
The Witcher is likely to see a
significant drop in streams from the
third season to the fourth In fairness
to all involved the future of the DC
Universe is still on Shaky Ground too
but that's another story
foreign